>>> FOR KEVIN MCCARTHY, 218 IS
THE MAGIC NUMBER, THOSE ARE THE
VOTES HE NEEDS TO BECOME HOUSE
SPEAKER WHEN REPUBLICANS TAKE
OVER IN JANUARY BUT WITH A SLIM
MARGIN HE'S GOING TO NEED EVERY
VOTE HE CAN GET.
IT'S GETTING TOUGHER.
FIVE REPUBLICANS SIGNALLED THEY
PLAN TO OPPOSE McCARTHY FOR
SPEAKER.
WHEN HE WAS ON THE SOUTHERN
BORDER HE SAID THEY MIGHT
IMPEACH THE HOMELAND SECURITY
SECRETARY IF HE DOES NOT RESIGN
FIRST.
>> IF SECRETARY MAYOR KAS DOES
NOT RESIGN, HOUSE REPUBLICANS
WILL INVESTIGATE EVERY ORDER,
EVERY ACTION, AND EVERY FAILURE
TO DETERMINE WHETHER WE CAN
BEGIN IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
>> WE HAVE A PLAN, WE'VE BEEN
PUTTING THAT FORWARD.
McCARTHY HAS NO PLAN.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY HAS NO
PLAN.
THEY DO NOTHING EXCEPT DO
POLITICAL STUNTS.
>> WE SHOULD NOTE THE DHS
SPOKESMAN SAID MAYORKAS HAS NO
PLAN TO RESIGN.
WE'VE BEEN LOOKING AT THE
NUMBERS FOR KEVIN McCARTHY WAND
IT'S NOT CLEAR CUT WHAT THE PATH
LOOKS LIE.
WHAT'S THE CONVERSATION ON
CAPITOL HILL RIGHT NOW?
>> Reporter: IT'S ALL ABOUT THE
NUMBERS GAME.
YOU AS YOU MENTIONED HE NEEDS
218 VOTES TO BE SPEAKER BUT
KEVIN McCARTHY IS PREDICTING HE
HAS 222 REPUBLICANS TOTAL IN THE
HOUSE.
WHICH DOING THE MATH HE CAN ONLY
AFFORD TO LOSE FOUR REPUBLICANS
IN THE SPEAKERS RACE.
HOWEVER A FIFTH REPUBLICAN CAME
OUT AND SAID HE'S GOING TO
OPPOSE McCARTHY ON THE FLOOR
VOTE IN JANUARY.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> A GROWING NUMBER OF US WHO
HAVE LOST FAITH THAT McCARTHY
CAN DO THE JOB.
THE SPEAKER IS THE MOST
IMPORTANT POSITION AT THIS TIME
IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Reporter: SO WHAT THAT MEANS
KAITLAN IS KEVIN McCARTHY IS
GOING TO HAVE TO CONVINCE ONE OF
THOSE MEMBERS TO CHANGE THEIR
MINDS OR CONVINCE TO NOT SHOW UP
TO THE VOTE WHICH WOULD LOWER
THE NUMBER HE NEEDS TO BE
SPEAKER AND KEVIN McCARTHY
BETTER HOPE THERE'S NOT MORE
REPUBLICANS WHERE THOSE CAME
FROM.
>> WE KNOW THERE'S AN EFFORT TO
PUT MORE REPUBLICANS ON THE
LIST.
HAS McCARTHY RESPONDED TO THIS?
ANYONE'S NAME SUGGESTED TO
TAKEOVER IF HE DOESN'T SECURE
THE VOTES TO BE SPEAKER?
>> NO ONE WOULD OUTRIGHT
CHALLENGE HIM BUT STEVE SCALISE,
JIM BANKS.
NONE OF THOSE PEOPLE WOULD
CHALLENGE KEVIN McCARTHY.
KEVIN McCARTHY HIMSELF HAS BEEN
MEETING PRIVATELY WITH SOME OF
HIS CRITICS.
HE'S BEEN MAKING PHONE CALLS.
HE HAS NOT CUT ANY DEALS JUST
YET.
I EXPECT THOSE TO COME IN THE
COMING WEEKS.
BUT HE'S TRYING TO PUBLICALLY
SHOW HIS CRITICS WHAT SORT OF
LEADER HE WOULD BE.
HE WAS ON THE SOUTHERN BORDER
YESTERDAY THREATENING SECRETARY
MAYORKAS WITH IMPEACHMENT.
CLEARLY THOSE COMMENTS WERE
DESIGNED TO WIN OVER CRITICS.
>> IT IS GOING TO BE AN
INTERESTING JANUARY.
WE HAVE A FEW WEEKS AHEAD.
>> YOU KNOW WHO I THINK WE
SHOULD BRING IN TALK ABOUT THIS?
CNN POLITICAL COMMENTATOR AND
HOST OF "SMERCONISH" LUCKILY HIS
NAME IS MICHAEL SMERCONISH.
GOOD MORNING, MICHAEL.
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH KEVIN
McCARTHY?
DOES HE HAVE THE VOTES AND WHAT
HE DID AT THE BORDER, IS IT A
STUNT?
SHOULD THEY BE TALKING MORE
ABOUT PRACTICAL, REAL SOLUTIONS
TO THE IMMIGRATION CRISIS?
>> DON, I THINK IT'S ALL
RELATED.
I THINK THE REASON HE'S ON THE
BORDER IS BECAUSE OF THIS ISSUE.
HIS DESIRE TO BE THE NEXT
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
I THINK THAT KEVIN McCARTHY HAS
THE WORST ODDS OF BEING THE NEXT
HOUSE SPEAKER EXCEPT FOR ALL THE
OTHER REPUBLICANS BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T BEAT SOMEBODY WITH NOBODY.
SO WHEN THE QUESTION BECOMES IF
NOT KEVIN McCARTHY, WHO?
THERE'S REALLY NO NAME YOU CAN
FILL IN THE BLANK THAT YOU'LL BE
ABLE TO HERD A SUFFICIENT NUMBER
OF CATS TO GET TO THE 218 OR
WHATEVER THE NUMBER MIGHT BE
BECAUSE THEY VOTE BY SURNAME, IT
COULD BE 216.
I DON'T SEE ANYONE WHO COULD
DENY HIM.
>> YOU SAY HE HAS THE WORST ODDS
BUT THINK HE'S GOING TO BE
SPEAKER?
>> IT'S MY WEAK ATTEMPT AT A
PUN.
HE HAS THE WORST ODDS EXCEPT FOR
ALL THE OTHERS BECAUSE I DON'T
SEE ANYBODY WITH BETTER ODDS
THAN HE DOES.